hey everyone Jared here and today we're
talking about the black hole that
devoured weeks of my life
fallout 4 like many of its predecessors
fallout 4 follows a vault dweller
bravely traversing the post-apocalyptic
wasteland
unlike fallout 3 which features a vault
dweller in search of his father
fallout 4 chronicles a weird inverted
Edible scenario where you kill your son
and destroy his legacy all Fallout games
feature super mutants death claws and
feral ghouls menacing the human race but
in fallout 4 there's a new danger
synthetic humans and while the perils of
the wasteland still pose an existential
threat to humankind
fallout 4 introduces a new purely
philosophical threat that is what does
it mean to be human
through the synths the game makes us
question everything we know about our
very humanity welcome to wisecrack
edition on the philosophy of Fallout 4
the scent creating Institute serves as
the primary antagonist to the rest of
the Commonwealth the Institute was built
when the surviving scientist of a
fictionalized MIT known as CIT dubbed
themselves underground to shield
themselves from the ravages of the
irradiated surface dedicating themselves
to research in the advancement of
humanity they quickly scrapped their
plans to improve life on the surface and
instead opted to create serene
waterfalls and creepy synthetic children
the institute's synth program draws
suspicion from the inhabitants of the
wasteland who believe correctly that the
institute is replacing their loved ones
with synthetic counterparts what have
you done with the real Riley where's my
brother
it also sets the Menards with the
railroad who believe the synths are
sentient and being exploited by the
Institute and the Brotherhood of Steel
who feel the synthetic humanoids are
another case of Technology gone too far
the fundamental question about synths
and our relation to them falls into two
camps
there's humanism a philosophy centered
on surprise the human and post humanism
the deconstruction and decentering of
what it means to be human
as the player one choice face in the
game is to believe as father does that
the synths are mere robots or you can
believe as the railroad does that
because they've developed sentience
they're deserving of rights we could see
the synth storyline as an uninspired
lazy cliche about discrimination I'd
never be friends with a
but it also does a great job of
exploring the line between human and
non-human nowhere is this divide
explored more explicitly than in the
ideology of the Brotherhood of Steel and
their opposition to the Institute the
Brotherhood are for like a better term
synth racist they believe the cybernetic
organisms are an abomination to nature
thus in a robotic abomination of
technology that is free think and
masquerades as a human being and it's
not just the fear of them being used by
the Institute to spy on society even the
rebellious synth shepherded to freedom
by the railroad our targets of Max and
soldiers we intend to end the synth
menace we need to plug the leaks walking
around Brotherhood territory with
Valentine and early version synth
subjects you to a deeply unsettling
level of harassment don't get any ideas
the Brotherhood ride around on the
prydwen led by a guy named Arthur a
reference to the ship and hero of the
tales of King Arthur their ranks emulate
medieval Europe with titles like Knight
paladin scribe and Squires this is
perhaps the best indication of how they
perceive themselves chivalrous Knights
out to battle monsters and protect a
helpless remains of humanity and its
purity the Brotherhood adopts a kind of
classical morality they believe in the
human as a pure inherently valuable
entity worth defending conceived in a
womb by a loving mother I'll not sure
all you get the idea they can be roughly
described as humanists now there are
tons of different kinds of human isms
who all believe different things but
we're really just using the term
humanists to stress a level of
assumptions they share with the other
humans that there is a basic human
nature and that the human as opposed to
the inhuman are the primary subjects of
the world if the Brotherhood is so
bothered by synths it's because this
amalgam of man and machine threatens the
very identity that defines them and the
humanity they seek to defend flesh is
flesh machine is machine the two were
never meant to intertwine long before
the Brotherhood humanity was obsessed
with defining themselves by what they
are not we're not like animals because
we use tools think abstractly and use
emojis back in the days of ancient
Greece this anxiety mainly manifested
itself in interspecies creatures like
centaurs and minotaurs the combination
of species disrupted the traditional
boundaries of Greek society between man
and
policin nature etc today that anxiety
about the boundaries of the human creeps
into our relationship with technology
instead of human versus animal it's more
like human versus animal / machine /
microbes / holy [__] the world of scary
stuff a quick survey of the sci-fi genre
will reveal a ton of movies scared
shitless about human genetic
manipulation machines overtaking humans
machines [__] humans you get the idea
in her essay the cyborg manifesto
philosopher Donna Haraway investigates
our construction of the human and how
this chasm between organism and machine
is always enforced by a kind of border
war we defend the figure of the human
against degradation
impurities infections and so on by
attempting to play God the Institute has
taken the sanctity of human life and
corrupted it beyond measure it shouldn't
be surprising to learn that back in the
day people argued that dialysis was an
unsavory attempt to play God an unholy
marriage between man and machine
life-saving technologies are often
considered undignified
in order to preserve their idea of pure
humanity the Brotherhood wants to
exterminate the synths who threaten
these boundaries the Brotherhood's
defense of the human isn't all that new
and their response to sense isn't too
surprising they're essentially railing
against miscegenation or the mixing of
races using the same indications of
purity in nature that have always worked
so well when being dicks to entire
groups of people
however the Brotherhood's idea of human
is deeply flawed and full of
contradictions
it's here that fallout gets pretty smart
even if inadvertently the game through
the Brotherhood of Steel shows the
distinction between human and inhuman
isn't so black and white I don't
recognize you and calls into question
several myths surrounding the very idea
of the human the first myth the
Brotherhood runs into is about the
purity of the human body shunning the
mixture of flesh and machine as we
discussed earlier the problem is they're
literally cyborgs if you want to rail
against the posthuman let's talk about
your suits of power armor that you wear
around everywhere the power armor
enhances the human body like any implant
could it can augment your vision your
strength / proctor ingram it even fills
the void - the missing legs she lost in
battle for hair away this boundary is
always a fiction and the biggest
enforcers of
border between human and human are
gleefully ignorant of how porous that
border is those things that make us
human
using tools language etc are seen in
both apes and birds
we're also molded according to Hera way
by the environment with the Commonwealth
corrupt you as it has everything else in
real life be pure human body is full of
foreign DNA and bacteria likewise the
radiation wreaking havoc on the DNA of
wastelands survivors makes them as
impure as the sins created with
untainted DNA from Sean the second myth
is about human nature and morality
Maxon argues against dance's humanity on
the grounds that those ethics that it's
driving a champion on even its own
they were artificially inserted in an
attempt to have it blend into society
for many humanists there's either a
human nature which makes us innately
good or at the very least a free will
which enables the possibility of ethics
unlike animals or machines we can choose
to be virtuous max and criticizes dance
for having artificially inserted ethics
the irony of this coming from a man
raised in a heavily regimented military
organization where higher powers dictate
a code of ethics to a set of
subordinates seems to be lost on him if
you intend to stay within our ranks you
need to obey our tenets without question
for Harraway our entire being is crafted
by the cultures societies and
environment that we come into contact
with for instance exploring Kellogg's
memories and his traumatic upbringing
can tell us as much about who he is as
his cybernetic implants if the Institute
inserted a set of ethics and dance is it
all that different from the ethics
instilled in us by our parents our
church or our schools technology
invading human nature is a constant fear
in real society and constitutes the
third myth espoused by the Brotherhood
using tools as what allowed us to evolve
into who we are today and the
technologies we developed along the way
like agriculture architecture and
manufacturing shaped us as much as we
shaped the world with them before the
sense the brotherhood manifested this
fear and their distrust of Technology
believing the pursuit of science to be a
reckless transcending of human
limitations and control these
monstrosity x' are just another example
of man
blindly taking a step forward only to
wind up stumble
two steps back yet at no point does it
register for them that flying around a
blimp stock full of nukes might also be
inactive Hughes the figure of the synth
creates a rupture and our understanding
of the human complicating these myths
for Haraway this is a good thing our
rigid conception of human is what allows
people to ostracize goals and enslave
synths and fall out it has justified
centuries of oppression against
racialized others whoa whoa no ghouls in
diamond city get that thing out of here
our way argues for a cyborgs politics
one that rejoices in the illegitimate
fusion of animal and machine in other
words instead of denying that we're
cyborgs we should embrace it we're not
only the fusion of flesh and machine but
society history and culture the
Institute even if accidentally manages
to confront us with this pollution of
the human father leaves you a synthetic
version of himself for you to raise as
your own child the sense who we're told
are mere automatons bristle for freedom
regardless of their categorization even
the fact that since are built using
actual human DNA further blurs these
boundaries Valentine who is aware he is
living with somebody else's memories
planted in his artificial mind
struggled with what it means to be
knowing that he and his past are
fabrications as I was Nick Valentine I
had his memories his fears all that poor
bastards hope then I discover all those
things that they weren't even mine
all the good we've done that's ours and
ours alone and even if that's the only
thing in this world that I can ever
claim as mine not Nick's not the
Institute's but mine and then there's
this speech from dance it's true I was
built within the confines of a
laboratory and some of my memories
aren't my own but when I saw my brothers
dying at my feet I felt sorrow when I
defeated an enemy of the Brotherhood I
felt pride don't you understand I
thought I was human Arthur
perhaps the most interesting lesson we
can draw from fallout 4 comes from the
story of Pinocchio in Pinocchio a wooden
marionette strives to become fully human
it's only when he learns the human
traits of selflessness and honesty that
he's finally transformed fallout offers
a few parallels there's Curie who wants
to
real human butt settles for her brain
being downloaded into a sin then there's
a relationship between father and the
synth Shawn he built which somewhat
parallels the relationship between
Gepetto and Pinocchio do you think you
could love him like you would a real boy
both dance and Valentine ground their
claims in humanity like the story of
Pinocchio in their human values and what
better metaphor for what it means to be
human than a puppet who only becomes a
human after he learns to obey his father
and accept society's rules hey everyone
thanks for watching if you're looking
for another post-apocalyptic property to
dive into head over to audible.com slash
wisecrack and download the gunslinger by
Stephen King the first book in The Dark
Tower series this is the book where King
introduces Roland of Gilead on his
spellbinding journey through a desolate
world which disturbingly mirrors our own
if you like deep dark end of the world
as we know it type stuff I'm sure you'll
dig the gunslinger audiobooks are a
great way to make time fly whether
you're on a soul-crushing commute
working out at the gym or trying to
avoid your friends and family over the
holidays audible makes it easy to enjoy
a huge selection of audiobooks original
audio shows comedy and more no matter
where you are just go to audible.com
slash wisecrack to start your free
30-day trial when you sign up you can
pick the gunslinger or any book you want
download it for free and it's yours to
keep forever
for more about audible and start your
free 30-day trial with a free audio book
go to audible.com slash wisecrack to
sign up and thanks to audible for
sponsoring this video and we've got a
ton more videos around the corner
including even more on Rick and Morty in
South Park to make sure you're in the
loop click here to visit our channel
page and subscribe while you're there
maybe check out our video on the
philosophy of Darth Vader and Happy
Holidays wisecrack now if the year is
coming to an end I've got some major
sleep to catch up on so thank you thank
you thank you and that's all for now
y'all peace
[Music]
you